at this stage of the course you always
forget two pieces of information you're
gonna get an equation to actually solve
its sword if you have any questions and
then you're going to get a domain okay
we'll come back to that in a second
you'll notice that I've put up a red
flag here wave my little red flag I
should actually get a red flag that'll
be really good and I would literally
pick up a raven because as I've
mentioned before there are some kinds of
questions and some particular skills
that come up again and again and again
and they form a critical part of other
things you need to solve okay so solving
tricky agents is one of them you will be
solving these for a long time and they
often form a really critical part of
some other problem right so you really
want to master these these are the kinds
of things you want to be able to do
without thinking really right now I said
you're going to get your equation and
then you'll get your domain okay why is
it why is it that you needed to remain
supplied with the question any takers
any questions okay so the first thing is
look this thinks you're gonna have more
than one solution right so so which one
okay that's the first point but secondly
there's something even more than that
it's got more than two solutions right
yeah good any tree crazy is right if
it's equal to some number assuming there
is a solution
if you don't supply a domain you're just
going to get solutions forever
let's have a look this is what cosine
looks like right and this is posing a
question when is cos x equal to 1/2 and
that happens rather a lot of times
there's one so 1/2 would be about there
and here are all my solutions
okay so you have to be watchful for this
there will come a time they will come a
time when we'll say no you know what you
can um you can give me a solution for
this and you can write it in such a way
that it captures all of the solutions
that are there and that's at all no
topic it's called general solution
because it means as a solution that's
generally always true look this this
clearly patterns here right that can be
taken advantage of but for now we're
just looking at it in a specific domain
okay so this is kind of your standard
domain it's not you know not every time
you're going to get this so you have to
read it carefully
another common ones between minus 180
and 180 but this is what we've got at
the moment
that's where cos x stops from naught to
360 okay so I've put it up there because
I think that's your most helpful way to
solve this let's give this a go
you know cos x equals 1/2 now 1/2 I
provided because it's an exact value
right what's the exact value of x in
degrees that would give you a 1/2 what's
your acute angle it's going to be 60
degrees right 60 degrees so I'll just
put this on the side view
sixty degrees is what we call and you've
heard these phrases before our base
angle or our related angle okay if you
put cos 60 into your calculator you
would get a half and likewise if you put
cos inverse of a half into your
calculator
you'd get 60 degrees assuming you're in
degrees okay but there's another
solution right so have a look at the
symmetry here you can see I'm going
forward 60 degrees and that gives me the
first solution looking at the symmetry
of this thing how do I again not just
what's the angle how do I get the other
angle what do I do
yeah good this is 0 and this is 360
right at the end right 360 so being that
they're going the same distance from
either side I'm going to have to
subtract 60 degrees which of course
gives us our solution 300 degrees okay
so I'm gonna say 60 degrees that's it
that's all there is to it okay
alternatively if you didn't want to
think in terms of the graph you would
think in terms of this you would say
okay look I've got cos and it's positive
so which two quadrants am i interested
in quadrant one and quadrant four right
tick tick okay so you tell all right
I've already got my 60 degrees in here
in order to go 200 4 I'm gonna go all
the way around until I get 60 degrees
there and that's 300 degrees right same
answers it's the same thing it's just
this is looking around the unit circle
okay there's my two solutions that's it